الرحمن الرحيم قال تعالى ولمن انتصر بعد
ظلمه فاولئك ما عليهم من سبيل صدق الله
العظيم انتصارا لمظلوم الشعب الفلسطيني
الذي يتعرض للعدوان الاسرائيلي المستمره
حتى هذه اللحظه وضمن الرد على العدوان
الامريكي البريطاني على بلدنا نفذت القوات
البحريه في القوات المسلحه اليمنيه عمليه
عسكريه نوعيه استهدفت سفينه تجاريه
امريكيه كول كانت متجهه الى موانئ فلسطين
المحتله وذلك بعده صواريخ بحريه مناسبه
اصابتها بشكل مباشر ان هذه العمليه تاتي
بعد ساعات فقط من استهداف القوات البحريه
في القوات المسلحه اليمنيه للمدمره
الامريكيه يو اس اس قفلي بعده صواريخ
بحريه في البحر الاحمر وكانت الاصابه
مباشره ودقيقه بفضل الله ان القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره في تقديم الدعم
والاسناد للشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه
وذلك بمنع الملاحه الاسرائيليه او المتجهه
الى مواني فلسطين المحتله في البحرين
الاحمر والعربي حتى وقف العدوان وادخال
الغذاء والدواء للشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه ستواجه
التصعيد الامريكي البريطانيه بالتصعيد ولن
تتردد في تنفيذ عمليات عسكريه واسعه
ونوعيه ردا على اي حماقه بريطانيه امريكيه
ضد اليمن العزيز
وتؤكد كذلك ان كافه السفن الامريكيه
والبريطانيه في البحرين الاحمر والعربي هي
اهداف مشروعه للقوات المسلحه اليمنيه
طالما استمر العدوان الامريكي البريطاني
على بلدنا والله حسبنا ونعم الوكيل نعم
المولى ونعم النصير عاش اليمن حرا عزيزا
مستقلا والنصر لليمني ولكل احرار الامه
صنعاء 20 من رجب
1445 لهجره الموافق للحدي من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه